the moral values that and the ethics
that that Google has definitely
influenced you know I think when Sergey
and Larry started the company they
really you know they were they were they
weren't in it for the money they started
it because they really wanted to create
something that one they wanted and two
they thought was going to change the
world and and and I think that that that
really held up with 23 me where we say
I'll time you know we're not we're not
here just to be it would be very easy
for us to say oh we just want to be
another kind of diagnostic company we
come up with something very simple we
really want to change the landscape you
know every single day we want it we want
to take on the hard problems we don't
want to just you know find a solution
and make money and leave it at that we
really want to keep evolving and take on
those hard problems so i think that
google's been really inspiring that way
and that they keep you know things like
the book silent like even you know all
these things that they're doing I'm I'm
continuously impressed by the challenges
that they take on and I hope that the
same thing happens for 23 me
the amount of information I think it's
we definitely are suffering from an
information overload but I believe that
there's going to be better and better
ways of organizing that information and
processing it so so that it's it will
enhance your daily life so even things
we were playing we have this having a
sort of once once a week i'll go through
on google earth and go sort of
essentially flying into a different city
and and we have this large monitor at
home and it's amazing resolution and and
I was in too bad in two thousand and I
can just walk around the streets and and
it's things like that it's not you know
that it beat now that i have a small
child and i can't travel as much that's
phenomenally it's phenomenally
interesting for me it's fun and I think
that that's how information and
technology just are going to impact our
lives more and more on the personal and
on the fun side and more and more I
think also on on the serious i think on
the medical side i think we're going to
get i'm really excited about radiology I
think I'm I've never seen there's a
there's a conference in Chicago every
every October and the stuff that's
happening in radiology is fascinating
and the stuff you can do with imaging
and I just think that technology and
information is it's overwhelming at the
moment but I think it's really going to
have a major it's really going to make
life better
you